un cap plusieurs orientations et d'abord
sur la question du pouvoir d'achat sujet
au coeur de la mobilisation des gilet
jaune l'impôt sur le revenu de 15
millions de foyers devraient bénéficier
d'une baisse de 5 milliards d'euros dès
2020 les deux premières tranches
seraient concernés pour les retraités le
président de la république a décidé de
ré indexer les retraites inférieures à
2000 euros par rapport au coût de la vie
autre point abordé les pensions
alimentaires impayées directement
prélevée par la caf et pour financer
notamment la diminution de l'impôt sur
le revenu emmanuel macron a lancé
quelques pistes
j'ai donc demandé au gouvernement de
mettre en oeuvre cette baisse d'impôts
en la finançant par la suppression de
certaines niches fiscales pour les
entreprises la nécessité de travailler
davantage et des réductions de notre
dépense publique
nous pouvons faire aussi bien en
dépensant moins et donc supprimer nombre
d'organismes inutile à propos des
institutions emmanuel macron souhaite
renforcer le statut des mers pas de
référendum d'initiative citoyenne voulu
parler gilet jaune mais une
simplification du référendum
d'initiative partagée avec un seuil fixé
à un million de citoyens
accompagné d'un droit de pétition sur
les sujets locaux
enfin une refondation du conseil
économique social et environnemental
avec l'intégration de 150 citoyens tirés
au sort
le président de la république a aussi
annoncé un nouvel acte de
décentralisation des politiques de la
vie quotidienne attribué spécifiquement
aux collectivités pour répondre au
manque de services publics en zone
rurale des maisons françaises vis
regroupant notamment la caf ou pôle
emploi devrait être déployé dans les
cantons enfin emmanuel macron souhaite
réorganiser les services de l'état dans
les collectivités en envoyant des
fonctionnaires parisiens sur les
territoires financement calendrier mise
en oeuvre toutes ces mesures seront
précisées par le gouvernement en
revanche le vote blanc et le retour de
l'impôt sur la fortune seront écartés
alors que ces points ressortait
majoritairement du grand débat national